ron futrell went out to red rock casino
in summerland where they are starting to
feel the
super bowl excitement that's so exciting
about this time of year is kind of the
the celebration of sports books
yes the books are busy this time of year
they've got a captive audience and a
classic matchup
with the chiefs favored over the box by
three
handel's been really really good
visitation has been good we've gotten a
lot of money on the chiefs on the point
spread
and conversely a lot of money on the
bucks on the money line
so there's fans looking there for tampa
to win the game and the chiefs to cover
the point spread
total points in the game is going down
they could have bad weather in tampa on
sunday
we've just had some late action on the
under so we're seeing a little bit more
big under wagers it's supposed to rain
or drizzle a little bit at game time and
through the beginning of the game so
maybe those turnovers begin to happen
and the rain might have a play on the
game
overall this has been a tough year for
casinos but sportsbooks have actually
been doing well
this is a great time of year for our
team members and we're really happy to
have the super bowl crowd so
please come in make your bets we've got
everything you know socially distanced
we've got the staffs up to the max of
people here we've got extended hours so
don't be afraid to come in and make your
super bowl wagers
kickoff is 3 30 sunday on cbs ron
futrell
8 news now